[Musique]
c'est ici en septembre 2010 est que 162
guérilleros du front 19 des farc ont
déposé les armes après avoir combattu
l'armée et les paramilitaires pendant
des décennies dans les montagnes
alentours la sierra de santa marta et la
cordillère du pèlerin
dans cet espace de formation et de
réincorporer sion il y en a 24 en
colombie en vertu de l'accord de paix de
2016 350 personnes tentent de survivre
dans ce petit village mais ce n'est pas
facile les habitations sont encore
temporaires une pièce de 4 mètres par 6
par foyer que ceux qui peuvent et c'est
d'agrandir les sanitaires sont communs
il y a une petite épicerie une salle à
manger une auberge pour les visiteurs et
bientôt experton pour les touristes
le dirigeant de la coopérative freij
escobar nous montre les plans de la
future citadelle de la baie est financée
uniquement par l'aide internationale car
le gouvernement dit van duc et fait tout
depuis quatre ans pour torpiller
l'application de l'accord de paix elle
installe colombiens et colombiennes ont
construit on assure
l'état n'a pas construit une seule
demeure en cinq ans la première maison
sera celle du projet eco tour de tirah
grata le plus prometteur l'ex guérillero
félix et le guide du cloud l'écho tour
le camp dément l'idée faire revivre aux
touristes la vie quotidienne des farc
dans la forêt pendant la guerre
les camps bucci un matelas de terre et
de feuilles entre quatre piquets au
centre du campement la abla lieu de
réunion pour la formation les cours les
fait aussi le débat sur les nouvelles de
la radio tous les soirs à 18h
à gauche le quartier des commandes en
plus loin là ranch à la cuisine jusqu'à
la fosse d'aisance les deux chanteurs
tout y est reproduit à l'identique mais
à petite échelle une quinzaine de
touristes sont déjà venus y passer 24
heures dit
ils ont une belle expérience par la
moindre nuisance ni le moindre bruit
cellulaire et à l'histoire de philips et
touchante abandonné par ses parents et
dix ans il devient paysans chez un oncle
une vie difficile
un mariage désastre beaucoup d'
humiliation
alors il s'enrôle dans la guérilla
c'était bien parce que la personne
n'était jamais humilier
médiation
[Musique]
pas question de renier le passé les farc
dans la maison de la mémoire les objets
souvenirs peinture sur l'histoire de la
violence vieilles radios des uniformes
la bibliothèque qui était resté caché
dans la forêt jusqu'en 2019
il a gardé son nom de guerre et le
directeur de l'écho tour
nous voulons un tourisme de mémoire et
de culture oui mon espace aux primes
conciliation de paix et de
réconciliation avec des sentiers de
randonnées d'observation d'oiseaux il y
à des espèces uniques dans les montagnes
et la forêt avec laquelle les farc était
en symbiose
c'était une question de survie que de se
cacher de l'aviation pour la relation -
marcos met la main à la pâte pour la
construction de la maison de l'éco tour
ensuite viendront les habitations pour
les familles
tout est fabriqué sur place
[Applaudissements]
retentit la ferronnerie les blocs de
ciment
tout ça grâce à l'aide internationale
mais ça ne suffit pas la communauté
survit à peine à cause du non respect de
l'accord de paix par le gouvernement au
complet
dès qu'on est loin de l'autonomie et de
la réincorporation économique social et
encore moins politique de bonnes sources
la majorité des 24 communautés de
réinsertion sont en difficulté manque de
moyens et discordes internes
[Musique]
la branche politique des ex far que
c'est le parti commu nes au congrès luis
alberto albane urbano alias marco scala
cas ex-négociateur des farc entame son
second mandat de représentant c'est l'un
des dix sièges réservés d'office aux
farc en vertu de l'accord de paix c'est
lui qui nous a dirigés vers tirera grata
parce que d'autres régions sont trop
dangereuses étaient les siennes tout
style dos santos
camara c'est une processeur une
corporation
332 ex farc ont été assassinés depuis
2016 dit le député la haine est
entretenu par le gouvernement du quai
qui s'était efforcé de ne pas appliquer
l'accord de paix est aigri et non c'est
quoi au story il ya un conflit qu'on est
là corp
watt39 perdre et qui a trente perdu
en
ville la réinsertion des facs n'est pas
facile non plus mais il y à des
réussites comme la brasserie alternativa
de la guérilla à la vierre artisanale et
la restauration pour manuel bolivar
après un début modeste cette grande
maison du quartier à la montée ou sa
quille on est devenu plus qu'un
restaurant une maison d'art et de
culture le succès du au bon repas et à
une bière brassée ici par d'anciens
guérilleros sous l'étiquette alternative
à
une micro brasserie qui a sa propre
marque la roja la rouge mais qui doit
tout importer
importer tout orge houblon car les
terres colombienne confisqué pendant la
guerre par des grands propriétaires n'en
produise plus
il y a quatre mois manuel a découvert
une bombe dans une toilette deuxième
étage il a pu à faire désamorcer mais il
a revécu la peur des menaces et des
attentats terroristes
le soir même 400 personnes sont venues
faire la fête en soutien à la casse
alternative à
manuel il a lancé un nouveau cocktail
bombe à la bombe
manuelle et tous les ex farc comptent
sur le nouveau président pour faire
respecter l'accord qu'ils ont signé en
promettant non
plus jamais la guerre